[Music]
we're not even invited to this thing
aren't we
nope
[Music]
uh mom's coming benjamin have you two
been smoking dope
yeah why can't you keep him under
control sons and anarchists mrs give him
for generations the given and wrath card
families had
a blood feud it was never about business
your son is trespassing
it was personal marry rascard ben
give it do i need to explain to you why
this is
unacceptable end it
it was an instant scandal
you take care of my problem i'll grant
you my daughter's hand
how do you want to die i want to die in
a gunfight choices they had made had led
them to this
very moment the fallout
it's not going to be pretty let's get
out of here
i always thought of my life like i was
living in my movie
i'm gonna be the star of your movie
this presents me with an issue keep your
friends close and your enemies closer
right dad
enough we're gonna piss a lot of people
off
do you have a death wish something that
excites you
dudes pretty much conform or die
honestly i'd rather die
put the fear of god in try to stop
us i'll protect you for how long
for as long as you want me to how about
forever
[Music]
foreign